[Musique]
bienvenue à déols à quelques pas du
château chanteurs chanteuses danseurs
danseuses paul danseuses transformiste
circassiens l'univers du cabaret n'aura
plus de secret pour moi est oui j'ai
décidé d'être au devant de la scène et
d'être audacieux alors on y est revenue
à l'audacieux cabaret
[Musique]
dita von teese marini pole dance vue
bonjour bonjour et bienvenue l audacieux
merci beaucoup victoria du victoria si
vous avez télé dans la salle vous avez
commandé rochus 6 3 je peux revoir le
geste comme ça que plein de grâce est
obligé d'y aller c'est obligé bonjour
marie non mais quelle aventure quand
même il fallait des cojones selon c'est
là dedans c'est le cas c'est une
aventure folle d'une dizaine d'années
on va présenter notre huitième saison
dès le mois de septembre la revue
sauvage alors qu'est ce qui s'y passe
donc le cabaret que vous allez
rencontrer bientôt anna coq et notre
performeuse paul danseuse après vous
retrouvez des circassiens chanteuses
chanteurs danseuses transformiste et qui
est le public de l'audacieux cabaret
vous avez des petits enfants grands
parents aux parents ils viennent en
famille viennent fêter des anniversaires
il ya des comités d'entreprise vraiment
maintenant ça devient on arrive à
attirer moi aussi je veux plonger là tu
veux tu m'emmènes voir quoi alors je
viens vous emmène voir anako donc à vous
initier à la pole dance
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs on l'a connu de
forts à la maison un accord alors anako
qui nous vient du japon j'ai quitté le
japon à 5 ans quand il retourner à 13
ans et puis ensuite j'ai décidé de
revenir vivre en france ça arrive qu'on
entend dans ta vie et la pole dance ça
arrive il ya une dizaine d'années
d'accord c'est vraiment par hasard
ça les amuse mois il est temps que tu me
laisse la place pour que je te montre un
petit peu mon niveau de pole dance
[Musique]
merci merci merci m
rebonjour victoria rebonjour kamini ont
nagé tenter de tout faire honneur qu'est
ce que tu en penses c'est validé par le
grand maître une vraie bêtes à plumes
j'adore comment on apprend à devenir
transformer en rencontre d'autres
artistes etc et dans les loges on a
toujours le plaisir de pouvoir les
regarder se maquiller en fin de compte
c'est un peu le geste traditionnel de la
maman qui qui va se maquiller de la
fille qui va regarder en fin de compte
et qui qui va me mais j'ai l'impression
que c'est quand même un métier de
partage et de générosité c'est la
générosité l'autre sont les essais
apporter du bonheur c'est partager et
faire oublier les tracas quotidiens en
fin de compte c'est ça notre métier en
fin de compte c'est savoir redonner le
sourire magie illusion vous allez voir
la puissance de victoria victoria qui va
se transformer en dalida ces cadeaux
c'est pour vous
[Musique]
m
c
[Applaudissements]
laissez moi
laissez moi danser et chanter en liberté
tout l'été laissez moi dans cette when
they will of oil est un large front de
terre